what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about the attack Titan there are
9 Titan powers altogether and so far
we've covered the other eight so in this
video I get to cover the final one which
also happens to be our main characters
main Titan we're going to cover
everything you need to know about the
attack Titan its unique powers and it's
past users if you enjoy attack on Titan
want to see more attack on Titan videos
make sure to smash that like one to let
me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and ring that notification
bell so you don't miss any future videos
and let me know what kind of attack on
Titan videos you would like to see in
the comments make sure to follow us on
Instagram for attack on Titan content
conversations and crucial updates lastly
there will be spoilers in this video
you've been warned now without further
ado let's jump into the video like the
other Titan powers the attack Titan was
once part of yamir Fritz the first
tighten according to LD and mythology
she split her power into nine different
Titans all of which had their own unique
abilities and strengths the attack Titan
is one of the nine titan powers the
first known possessor of this power
after yamir Fritz was the owl also known
as Aaron Krueger in a previous video
people kept commenting that it's not air
and Krueger but Eren Yeager and so I
just want to make it clear that these
are two different characters Eren Yeager
was probably even named Aaron as a way
for Grisha to pay respect to Kruger if
you didn't know our main story takes
place on the island of paradise where
the three walls are located people in
the walls think that they're the last
remnants of humanity but they're not
life goes on outside of the walls and
the LD ends the only people who can
become Titans are being oppressed by a
nation called Marlay LD ends are treated
as monsters and devils the owl aka air
and Kruger is actually a double agent
who pretends to be a Marlon officer but
is secretly working to overthrow the
Marlon nation and restore LD and freedom
as a kid Ehren Kruger who looked a lot
like Eren Yeager when he was a kid
watched from a closet as Marlon officers
mercilessly burned LD and rebels to
death
including his father he was then saved
by friends of his father's before his
house burned down rather than being
scared into submission Krueger vowed to
get revenge on Marley and to restore el
dia in this way he was a lot like Aaron
when he wanted revenge against the
Titans
he became a double agent pretending to
be an officer for the greater good as he
saw it he had to maintain appearances so
he was often forced to take the fingers
of the LDN people he wanted to protect
he skinned them alive turned them into
Titans also he could keep his true LD
and identity from being revealed Kruger
already a grown up Marley an officer by
this time and his partner gross ran into
Grisha and his sister one fateful day
when they went beyond the walls of the
Libero internment zone this zone is a
place where LD ants are not supposed to
leave without permission
like Aaron Yeager who wanted to go
beyond the walls on the island of
paradise Grisha wanted to go beyond the
walls of the internment Zone so that he
could show his sister an airship this is
when he ran into Kruger and gross since
the two kids had no exit permits they
had to pay either through labor or
punishment Kruger had a kid Grisha in
the stomach with his knee while gross
took Fay away we later find out that she
was ripped apart by dogs for grosses
amusement by beating him up Kruger
actually saved Grisha from a similar
fate later Kruger kept doing his double
agent thing while Grisha grew up he
became a doctor and ended up joining a
secret group called the LD and
restorationist who got Intel from Cougar
who was known to them as the owl Grisha
meets and marries his first wife the
Royal blooded Deena Fritz and has a
child with her they named him Zeek
Yeager who ends up becoming the Beast
Titan while his mother ends up becoming
the smiling Titan they put Zeek in a
Marlon warrior program to be a double
agent like owl but when he heard that
the Marlins were close to catching the
LD and restorationist Zeek sold out his
parents so that he could save his
grandparents and maintain the image of a
loyal Marlon warrior all the
restorationist were taken to the outer
seawall
on the island of parodies to be turned
into Titans Kruger was there when Grisha
was the only one from his party left and
gross was about to push him off Kruger
steps in and pushes grouse off he then
turns into the attack tightened he
raises the entire merlion ship and
breaks it in half thus we can see that
the attack titan possesses extraordinary
strength Ian for a titan eren yeager
would later use this strength to plug a
hole in the wall
by carrying a giant boulder to it Kruger
kills all of them are laying soldiers
and reveals the truth to Grisha
Kruger picked him as the successor to
his Titan power because of his hatred
for male and because he chose to go
outside the wall of the internment zone
so many years ago it's the desire to
seek freedom that made him want to
choose Grisha most of all Kruger tells
us that the attack Titan is associated
with freedom it has always moved ahead
seeking freedom it has fought on for
freedom that's the most specific
information we get about the attack
Titan it seems to be the natural enemy
of the founding Titan who has been used
to trap people within walls and keep
them trapped we also know that this
Titan must be very important because the
title of the series actually nods
towards this specific Titan power in
fact in the Japanese this Titans name
attacked Titan and the name of the
series attack on Titan share the same
name shingeki no kyojin so it will
likely turn out to be the most important
power of all for the series another
interesting moment is when Aaron Krueger
seems to get access to Eren Yeager's
future memories of Armin and Mikasa he
mentions both of them to Grisha this is
the only time we saw a Titan Power
helped someone potentially get a glimpse
into the future thus this may be one of
the attack Titans powers the ability to
see into the future or at least get
access to the memories of future
possessors if Aaron could learn to
control this power it would definitely
come in handy when it came to preparing
for future battles or carrying out his
goals this ability to seemingly see into
the future
one of the most interesting unexplained
mysteries in attack on Titan moving on
with the story
Grisha takes the power and uses it to
make it to the wall he marries Carla and
has a son our protagonist who he names
Aaron before he gives the attack time to
Aaron he confronts Frida Reese the
possessor of the founding Titan he uses
the attack Titan to overpower the
inexperienced Frida and steal the
founding Titan power from her he then
lets his son eat him and in doing so
gives him both Titan powers as
previously mentioned one of Aaron's
accomplishments includes carrying a
giant boulder and using it to plug a
hole in the wall we haven't seen other
Titans pick up such huge boulders or
ships like Kruger did so we can assume
that the attack Titan has a more
impressive strength to body size ratio
than other Titans although he puts up a
good fight for having less experience in
training he does lose to Annie's female
Titan in his first fight with her
partially because Annie is so skilled in
combat in their second battle annie is
more on the defensive in the manga she's
beating eren's Titan until the attack
Titan catches her kick in his mouth
Annie freeze her Titans like she has
heard the attack tight enough to make
her escape but mica says fast enough to
cut her down from the wall and the
attack Titan is there to pin her down
afterwards in the manga she seemed to
have the upper hand against Aaron the
whole time but she was outnumbered and
that worked against her the anime
version was quite different though in
the anime and he doesn't just beat up
the attack Titan and run away after she
kicks his face in Aaron gets angry and
actually enters a new form his berserk
mode his Titans eyes glow blue and it's
even on fire with lava like veins
glowing across his Titan body while
annie reaches the walls without any
problems as the manga the berserk mode
in the anime allows Eren to catch up to
Annie and tackle her to the ground
Eren who appears I've completely lost it
goes on to crush the female Titans face
the berserk mode seems to be defeating
the female Titan before she lands a kick
that sends Aaron flying and she takes
that window of time to start climbing up
the wall in the anime the berserk mode
makes it seem like Aaron
overpowered Annie if she didn't run away
while in the manga she wanted to escape
not because she feared Aaron would beat
her but because she knew that the rest
of the survey Corps including Mikasa and
Levi Ackerman would be too much for her
to handle alone and she wanted to make
it back to her father in the animate the
reserve Titan even manages to catch up
and hang on to the female Titans leg
slowing her down and taking one of her
legs before he falls down clearly this
is a big change we get a
never-before-seen form and the attack
Titan is made to seem much stronger in
the anime than in the manga at this
point the manga version was being bested
by a nice Titan while the anime berserk
version was wrecking Annie who seemed to
have no chance of winning against them
and so had to desperately run for her
life what do we make of this anime only
berserk mode that activated and clearly
made Aaron's attack Titan already known
for its strength even stronger it
reminded me of an avatar like state
where Aaron was no longer in control but
his Titan got a huge power boost and
acted on its own
should we dismiss this as anime only
non-canon stuff well I don't think so
II say Amma has said in interviews that
he did work with the anime creators and
that he did tell them how he would have
done some stuff differently if he could
do it again maybe this was an important
moment of foreshadowing he would have
put into manga if he had the chance
perhaps this scene this berserk mode
relates to what Kruger said that the
attack Titan has always moved ahead
seeking freedom it has fought on for
freedom he doesn't say attack time users
he specifically says the attack Titan
itself has fought on for freedom to me
this avatar like state could be a unique
power of the attack Titan that will come
into play again later in the series
perhaps when freedom is threatened and
aaron has reached his limit the attack
Titan will take over enter this berserk
mode and fight on in his place for
freedom moving ahead seeking freedom
even after its user is no longer
conscious all we can do is theorize at
this point but I think that this is the
best explanation for berserk mode right
now
perhaps it will turn out to be anime
only but that would be a bear
strange decision for the anime creators
if they never go on to explain this
clearly distinct form Aaron goes on to
defeat the armored Titan in his attack
Titan form he borrows moves he learned
from Annie but it's still crazy that he
could best Reiner who had way more years
of experience in training up to this
point
Reiner needs to be saved by Beth told
and this is even before Aaron in just
the armored Titan serum and is able to
harden his titans fists to the point
where he could break riders armor with
punches alone after ingesting the serum
Eren is able to harden his Titans whole
body and that hardened body will remain
even after he has detach from it later
after the time-skip Aaron goes on to
with me kisses help defeat the jaw Titan
and take the Warhammer Titan power for
himself now in addition to having the
attack times power
Eren also has access to Warhammer Titans
versatile weapons
he used the two Titan powers to hold his
own against Marlay and it's three Titan
powers after they showed up on the
island of parodies he not only held out
long enough for Zeke to show up but he
didn't take any serious damage while he
was fighting so many enemies truly an
impressive feat so that's what we know
about the attack Titan for now we know
it's ridiculously strong we know that it
always goes on seeking freedom we know
that it can now use hardening however
some things remain a mystery it appears
to be able to tell the future and it
appears to be able to enter an avatar
like overpowered state but these powers
have not been explored or explained to
us in detail especially because the
attack Titan shares the name of the
entire series in the Japanese language I
think that it will play an important
role as the series wraps up I'd say it
has to be a key factor in counteracting
the wish to entrap people within walls a
wish that the founding Titans seems to
be associated with especially after the
first King's philosophy started to take
hold of royal blood and founding titan
successors I believe that partially
because of the attack titan eren will
keep on moving forward seeking freedom
for the LDN people as a result I don't
believe that
Eren will actually help execute the
expand I'll plan which is to strip the
LD ins of their freedom
to shape their own futures Zeke wants to
erase them from existence while the
attack Titan seems to want them to keep
moving forward and to never give up and
that is it for today's video thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed the
video make sure the warhammer smash that
like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to get notified
when the new attack on Titan videos come
out for even more attack on Titan
content conversations and updates follow
us on Instagram at anime uproar a big
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who help make these videos
possible I especially want to thank our
pro hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh chubs is the man and nothing
but a fan and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans baby
Rey a17 FFT P Steven and Radha al-hola
autumn and Matty Mac 2 3 9 if you enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon comm anime uproar
and becoming a patron today for as
little as $1 if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin if
you're interested anyways thanks again
for all of your support and until next
time see us space cowboys
[Music]